いっ
えっ
[音楽]
てくるよ
入ってきたからまたって初めてなんですけどあー俺もその声も誰か知ってるよなんか
よく俺に毒気ゴキブリだけてくる人でしょ
も知ってるよ本当に知ってる知ってる知ってる a
ビートボクサーでしょビートバッターではない a beat box なんだよ
ビートボクサーじゃないでしょいやをリピートボクサーで本当だよ
ハロハロって言ってるんじゃねほんとにじゃあ何かっていやちょっとじゃあ俺のビート
ボックス聞いてんじゃねーよ
フィードボックスできるでしょできるできる行くよああ
あっはお前号ないご迷惑そうだよってがなんで入ってきたんですか僕の家なんですけど
いやだっていつも動画なんか晒してるじゃんヘアだからさあここかなぁと思って入っ
たらさあドンピシャだったんだよね
桜を特定したってことを言うんですよ直停止マスター3 c
えっマジかうんごめんねいや別に全然いいけどでもまあ僕今までの人と全然違うから
危害加えないから本当に何もしないよやば今までの人も気がいくん
いやーあいつらは機で加えようとしたところを見つかっただけだから
でもキミあれだよ手足ないよえっ
じゃあ自分の体を把握してないけど手足ないフェアしないってやつないそうだよしっ
てるよ手足ないからこそだよ
だけ痩せないからこそ何もしないよ何があると思うなに何があると思う
宿に
バターも
どんな者はどんな形ではどっち形
手足ないんでしょを養う
あのまたマトリョーシカなんでまあまあ撮れを誓うだよ
あの実はいヒトからヒトにご
人の中に人が入ってその中に人が入ってその中に人が入るロシアの人形
ああ
ちょっと違う何えら手足内の持ってやしないよ
何星なんか資格へ四角い館図
四角くて提案知らないお前雨はトミック
黙れでもう自分を把握しないっていうことはピザ窯がターンがエイサーや遠隔操作でき
ているかたんだな違う違う the
俺はそこにいる嘘だ言うよ.お前今めっちゃはないなの服はなんでしょ
薄くっ
ボタンあるでしょ
れちゃうねチャックついているチェックが付いただきまーす
ああああああああ
どんな cad 違うんだよ助け a
ザーグな家拉致しがわからない
自分自身がわかんないどうした
いいし
[音楽]
いいした